Les modèles de programmation sont des spécifications fondamentales qui définissent
comment le logiciel est structuré
et exécuté — ils fournissent un cadre
pour permettre aux développeurs d'exprimer des algorithmes
et d'organiser le code, en faisant souvent abstraction des détails bas niveau
du matériel sous-jacent ou de l'environnement d'exécution
différents modèles sont adaptés à différents types de problèmes
et architectures matérielles, en offrant
différents niveaux d'abstraction
et de contrôle. Dans ce chapitre,
on va passer en revue les modèles de programmation quantique et classique
et voir comment on peut les combiner pour faire fonctionner des algorithmes
à grande échelle
on va commencer par le modèle de programmation
pour un ordinateur quantique. Un modèle de programmation fondamental
que connaissent presque tous les développeurs quantiques
est le quantum circuit. On ne va pas
entrer dans les détails des quantum circuits
ici, car on a déjà beaucoup de super ressources,
dont un cours de Joan Waters.
On mentionnera seulement que le circuit est composé
d'un ensemble de lignes appelées fils, qui représentent des qubits,
ainsi que de gates, qui représentent des opérations sur les états quantiques,
et d'un ensemble de mesures.
Un autre concept important du modèle de programmation
pour
ces primitives représentent les tâches les plus courantes
que les utilisateurs cherchent à accomplir avec l'ordinateur quantique.
Il y a deux primitives disponibles à ce moment-là :
Sampler et Estimator. Sampler te donne la capacité
d'échantillonner un état préparé par un quantum circuit,
et Estimator te permet d'estimer la valeur d'expectation
d'une observable pour un système dans l'état préparé par ton quantum
circuit. Le dernier concept
dont on va parler dans cette section
est la transpilation. La transpilation
est le processus de réécriture d'un circuit d'entrée donné
pour correspondre à la topologie d'un appareil quantique
spécifique
en vue de son exécution sur des ordinateurs quantiques bruités.
Comme pour les compilateurs classiques,
une routine de transpiler modifie progressivement
la structure du circuit en appliquant un ensemble de passes.
Parlons maintenant des modèles de programmation classiques.
Il existe de nombreux modèles de programmation
pour les ordinateurs classiques,
mais dans ce chapitre on va se concentrer sur deux :
la programmation parallèle, le plus populaire,
et les workflows par tâches. En utilisant ces deux modèles
en combinaison avec les modèles de programmation quantique,
on peut exprimer à peu près n'importe quel workflow hybride
quantique-classique, quelle que soit sa complexité.
Le modèle de programmation parallèle
divise un programme en sous-problèmes qui peuvent être exécutés
en même temps. Il y a deux grands paradigmes de programmation parallèle :
le parallélisme à mémoire partagée et le parallélisme à mémoire distribuée.
Pour nos besoins ici, concentrons-nous sur le modèle à mémoire distribuée.
Un modèle à mémoire distribuée
utilise des processus indépendants sur des cœurs séparés
ou des nœuds, où chaque processus a sa propre mémoire
et la communication se fait par passage de messages. Il y a
quelques concepts qu'il est utile de connaître.
Le premier est le processus,
qui est une instance indépendante du programme
s'exécutant sur un cœur séparé.
Ensuite le rank, qui est un identifiant unique du processus,
et puis il y a le modèle d'abstraction Single Program
Multiple Data —
qui est un modèle d'abstraction
pour le calcul où une seule instance du programme
est distribuée à plusieurs nœuds.
Donc le code source est identique,
mais les données sur ces nœuds sont différentes.
L'exécution dans le modèle de programmation parallèle
se déroule de la façon suivante :
un seul programme est distribué à plusieurs nœuds
et lance plusieurs processus parallèles.
Le flux de contrôle du programme est dicté par le rank,
c'est-à-dire l'identifiant du processus,
et la communication se fait
par passage de messages.
Un modèle de programmation par workflow de tâches
abstrait le calcul en un graphe ou DAG,
où chaque nœud du graphe est une tâche particulière
ou un job, et les arêtes représentent les dépendances de données
et l'ordonnancement. Des exemples sont disponibles dans notre documentation.
Après tout, la séquence dont on parle toujours en informatique
quantique — mapping, optimisation,
exécution et post-traitement —
est un modèle de programmation par workflow de tâches
où toutes les tâches sont exécutées les unes après
les autres dans le pipeline.
Mais avec les workflows de tâches,
on n'est pas limité à un ordre d'exécution séquentiel
et on peut exécuter des tâches en parallèle.
Chaque tâche ou workflow peut être un job parallèle complet
en lui-même, donc tu peux mixer
et combiner ces modèles pour décrire des algorithmes
de n'importe quelle complexité.
Essayons d'appliquer certains des concepts qu'on a appris
au code. D'abord on va essayer de lancer un simple hello world
en utilisant le paradigme de programmation parallèle.
On va utiliser Open MPI,
qui est l'implémentation du protocole MPI,
qui est le standard pour le passage de messages
en programmation parallèle.
D'abord on a besoin d'avoir notre programme prêt.
Ici on utilise mpi4py,
qui est le binding Python
pour MPI, et comme tu peux le voir, on utilise le rank ici pour décider
du flux de contrôle du programme.
Regardons maintenant notre script de soumission.
Comme tu peux le voir, on va utiliser deux nœuds,
une tâche par nœud, sur la partition normale.
Et lançons notre programme — on va attendre un peu
puis on pourra vérifier les résultats de notre job.
Comme tu peux le voir, on a les sorties de log de notre programme.
Ici on a utilisé deux nœuds et deux processus
qui sont identifiés par un rank.
Comme tu peux le voir ici dans la sortie,
rank zéro et rank un, utilisés pour décider
du flux de contrôle de notre programme.
Comme tu peux le voir, le processus rank zéro a envoyé
une charge utile au processus rank un,
et le processus rank un l'a reçue.
Parlons aussi des workflows de tâches.
Il existe des outils appelés systèmes
de gestion de workflows, spécialement conçus
pour exécuter des workflows complexes.
Mais pour ne pas te surcharger, on va utiliser la fonctionnalité
de dépendance intégrée dans Slurm
pour construire ces groupes de calcul.
D'abord on a besoin d'avoir les tâches de notre workflow
prêtes. C'est le même code.
L'avantage d'avoir chacune de ces tâches —
mapping, optimisation, exécution,
post-traitement — comme étapes séparées,
c'est qu'on peut spécifier des besoins en ressources uniques
pour chaque tâche. Par exemple, mapping, optimisation
et post-traitement n'ont pas besoin
d'accéder aux ressources quantiques,
donc on peut les exécuter sur la partition classique.
Mais la tâche d'exécution aura besoin
de ressources quantiques, donc on va la lancer sur la partition quantique.
Utilisons maintenant la fonctionnalité de dépendance pour enchaîner les tâches
dans un workflow.
Comme tu peux le voir, on est en train d'exécuter
notre commande sbatch avec le flag --parsable,
qui va retourner l'ID du job,
et ensuite on peut passer cet ID de job
comme dépendance à d'autres tâches.
Pour les jobs, comme tu peux le voir, on lance
des jobs dans le workflow avec la dépendance.
Une fois que le workflow complet est terminé, on peut vérifier les résultats.
Et comme tu peux le voir, on a récupéré notre valeur d'expectation.
Et on peut aussi vérifier l'ensemble des
résultats de chacune des étapes.
Qui sont aussi présents ici.
Et c'est tout pour la section sur les modèles de programmation.
Dans le prochain chapitre, on va parler des algorithmes variationnels.